did you ever
battle the mpaa to try to get pg-13
originally when we all started on this
we
we thought it was going to be a rated r
film uh warner's then
dictated that it had to be pg-13 because
of what it cost
and we actually kind of followed we got
the sort of list of guidelines of what
you can do and you can't do
in a pg-13 movie and we followed those
rules
to a t i mean the amount of times you
can say
the kinds of nudity the blood the
violence
all of those things and
we screened it for the mpaa and i mean i
remember
hearing that they got about five minutes
in and put their notepads down and said
that we got a hard r
for tone and so this is not something
that's on the list but basically there's
this sort of i think it was an
overwhelming sense of dread was
what i heard that they had from the
opening scene onward
and they they didn't think there was
anything that we could do about it
basically what we had was a pg-13 movie
that got an r rating and so which just
killed me because it's like we were
going to get an r rating i would have
made an r rated movie
you know we could have like really gone
for it in
in terms of intensity and you know
violence and language and all those
kinds of things but
we we got a bit screwed on that on that
front and we did try to fight but
um we obviously didn't win that battle
it's uh do you think if it was released
today it would still get an r
for tone or do you think that the things
of the goal post has moved
there's a kind of weird subset of uh
religious horror
and uh that seems to get an r
much more quickly what you learn is that
despite the fact that there are
guidelines it's a purely subjective
interpretation and
that there and that subjectivity has
sort of like
it ends and flows based on the group
that is
uh designating the rating but very
we have a lot of demons demons
seem for some reason to trigger an r
rating there you have it
i've now given every prospective
filmmaker the key
to getting an r rating just have demons